und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und claus kleber guten
abend es war echt schwer heute den
überblick zu behalten über das was
bezüglich syrien geschah annegret kramp
karrenbauers pläne für einen auch
deutschen einsatz dort die frisch blüte
türkisch russische freundschaft ein
amerikanischer präsident der gerade
jetzt da ihn zu diesem thema kaum noch
eine ernst nimmt einen weiteren
glorreichen trump erfolg verkündet und
zur feier des tages alle sanktionen
gegen die türkei aufhebt als wäre das
alles gelöst
was ist natürlich nicht ist überblick
über einen verwirrenden tag von kamran
zafira
sie kontrollieren die grenze und suchen
nach verbliebenen kurdischen kämpfern
russische und syrische truppen anderswo
hießen die gewinner bereits triumphieren
die re flaggen türkische soldaten auf
einem ehemaligen kurdischen
hauptquartier nach dem russisch
türkischen deal von sochi gestern gilt
den abzug der kurden aus dem umkämpften
gebiet sollen zunächst syrische und
russische truppen sicherstellen nach
sechs tagen übernehmen damm türkische
und russische soldaten
sie sind die großen verlierer die kurden
sie haben schlimmes erlebt auch frauen
und kinder fast 180 tausend menschen
mussten fliehen
er feiert sich als grosser gewinner
us-präsident trump dabei hatte seinen
truppenabzug den türkischen angriff in
nordsyrien erst ermöglicht die türkische
regierung hat uns heute morgen darüber
informiert dass ihre streitkräfte die
offensive in syrien stoppen
sie machen den zeitlich begrenzten
waffenstillstand zu einem dauerhaft tram
kündigte zudem an die us-sanktionen
gegen die türkei jetzt wieder aufzuheben
sie hat ihre idee einer schutzzone in
nordsyrien heute verteidigt annegret
kramp-karrenbauer bei der truppe in
erfurt viel aufmerksamkeit und viel
kritik hat sie für ihren vorstoß
geerntet heute präzisiert sie ihre idee
nach vorne zu treiben ein prozess der
idealerweise enden sollte in einem
mandat der vereinten nationen un in
einer mission die auch von den vereinten
nationen geführt wird ob es am ende zu
dieser lösung kommen wird kann im moment
keiner garantieren immer noch irritiert
außenminister maß er hat heute die
ministerin aufgefordert konkrete inhalte
zu ihren plänen zu liefern
morgen will kramp-karrenbauer bei einem
nato-treffen in brüssel um verbündete
für ihren syrien vorstoß werben der
nato-generalsekretär vorsichtig erfreut
ich begrüße das alliierte vorschläge
haben wie eine politische lösung
aussehen kann
am ende werden sie die verlierer bleiben
protestierende kurden heute in
nordsyrien unser reporter jörg brase ist
an der türkisch syrischen grenze jörg
entwickelt sich die lage in dem gebiet
auf das es ankommt so positiv friedlich
wie erdogan putin trump das heute
beschreiben
na ja es gab ja heute die ersten
patrouillen syrischer und russischer
kräfte dass es dabei zu zwischenfällen
gekommen ist das haben wir nicht gehört
auch die türkei hat ja weitere
militärkräfte nachgeführt in die von ihr
kontrollierte region
aber ob das jetzt dauerhaft zu friedlich
bleibt daran kann man sicherlich zweifel
haben wenn man sich erinnert
das was im vergangenen jahr passiert ist
als die türkei weiter im westen die
region afrika eingenommen hat damals kam
es zu massiven übergriffen durch mit der
türkei verbündete islamistische kräfte
damals gab es plünderungen da gab es
auch hinrichtungen und davor haben
natürlich auch die menschen hier weiter
im östlichen grenzverlauf angst in der
kurdisch dominierten millionen stadt
kamischli gab es heute auch erste
proteste gegen das russisch türkische
abkommen die menschen fordern dass es
keine politische entscheidungen hier
geben darf ohne dass die kurden daran
beteiligt werden und auch was den
rückzug der epg milizen an gibt da gibt
es noch viele offene fragen viele der
kämpfer haben ja ihre familien im
grenzbereich leben sie werden diese zu
diesen familien zurückkehren wollen und
die türkei hat bereits bedenken geäußert
hat gesagt es kann nicht sein dass die
kurdische medien ihre uniform tauschen
und syrischer uniform der
regierungsarmee anziehen russland sagt
das werde nicht geschehen wie man das
allerdings überprüfen oder garantieren
will das ist mir noch schleierhaft da
gibt es also jede menge
konfliktpotenzial mal abgesehen von den
e s kämpfern die aus den gefängnissen
ausgebrochen sind und deshalb kann ich
mir nicht städten nicht vorstellen dass
es dauerhaft friedlich bleiben wird
weiter ein spannungsgebiet dankeschön
jörg in berlin im deutschen bundestag
wurde heute darüber diskutiert wie es um
die meinungsfreiheit in deutschland
bestellt ist
dieses thema fällt nicht vom himmel
überall hört man graue dass man die eine
oder andere wahrheit ja leider nicht
mehr sagen dürfe die alternative für
deutschland zieht energie aus diesem
gefühl und tut alles dafür dass es sich
weiter verbreitet mit auftritten in
allen medien wo sie ihre positionen
durchaus gut vertreten kann
auf der anderen eher linken seite ist
die erregung über solche rechte
kampagnen derart groß dass deren
meinungsäußerungen niedergeschrieben
werden im beglückenden gefühl dass man
dafür ein höheres recht auf seiner seite
habe christiane hübscher über eine
aktuelle stunde im bundestag und die
aktuelle lage im land nicht nur wenn sie
gesetze verletzt
[Musik]
es gibt kein recht auf nazi-propaganda
skandieren heute linke demonstranten an
der hamburger ohne bernd lucke hatte
hier zum zweiten mal versucht unter
erhöhten sicherheitsvorkehrungen eine
vorlesung über makroökonomie zu halten
nach einer stunde wird der hörsaal von
der antifa gestürmt schon letzte woche
war der afg gründer der die partei
allerdings verlassen hat bevor sie zur
anti migrations partei wurde von den
studenten vom hof gejagt worden
zur meinungsfreiheit gehört gerade das
recht auch die meinung des anderen
anzugehören und zu respektieren
das heißt ich kann durchaus sagen dass
mir etwas nicht gefällt aber ich darf
nicht verhindern dass jemand seine
meinung oder seine wissenschaftlichen
auffassungen in der universität frei
äussert der bundestag reagiert heute auf
verlangen der fdp mit einer aktuellen
stunde zum stand der meinungsfreiheit in
deutschland wenn wir uns nicht von
solchen rechtsbrüchen klar distanzieren
gerade wenn es vertreter der anderen
seite des politischen spektrums betrifft
dann machen wir uns über kurz oder lang
selbst mitschuldig an der verrohung des
gesellschaften des kurses
unsere gesellschaft hat im großen und
ganzen fahren lernt mit
unterschiedlichen meinungen aller ruhe
umzugehen und da müssen wir aushalten
dass menschen ihre meinung sagen
fraktionsübergreifend herrscht einigkeit
dass nicht sein darf was vorgestern auch
ex- bundesinnenminister thomas de
maizière passiert seine buchlesung bei
einem göttinger literaturfest wird von
linken aktivisten blockiert 300 zahlende
gäste kommen nicht rein
de maizière muss unverrichteter dinge
wieder abziehen
die aggressive blockade solcher art
richtet sich richtete sich gegen mich
aber die leidtragenden demokratische
bürger
bürger sie wurden in mithaftung genommen
für die meinungs- kampagne einer
radikalen politischen minderheit
politischer protest den selbst alt 68er
kritisieren ist ein skandal wenn an
universitäten auch in theatern museen
menschen denen deren meinungen wir nicht
teilen nicht mehr reden dürfen und daran
gehindert werden
diese orte sind die letzten orte freien
diskurses wären den sozialen medien sich
alle in ihren echo kammern verschanzen
einstecken müssen dabei alle seiten
farbbeutel attacken auf wahlkreisbüros
drohungen gegen politiker auch merkel
bekam sie zu hören die hau abrufe wer
also hat schuld am vergifteten klima
genau da zeigte im bundestag heute
wieder jeder nur zur anderen seite eine
blaue decke der politischen korrektheit
hat sich über das land gelegt offene
debatten über zentrale zukunftsfragen
unserer gesellschaft sind fast nicht
mehr möglich und schuld daran sind nicht
die bösen populisten schuld daran ist
ihre politik wird der altparteien nun
dürfen uns keinen illusionen hingeben wo
diese dinge her kommen sie kommen von
rechtsaußen und haben ihre
repräsentanten in dieser truppe gefunden
jeder hat das recht seine meinung in
wort schrift und bild frei zu äußern und
zu verbreiten eine zensur findet nicht
statt so will es das grundgesetz
widerspruch gehört dazu aber grenzen hat
auch die meinungsfreiheit die juristin
ehemalige ministerin und grünen
politikerin renate künast hat
erfahrungen mit aggressivsten
meinungsäußerungen im netz sie wurde
dort schon als [ __ ] sondermüll
[ __ ] und viel schlimmeres bezeichnet
und muss das laut landgericht berlin als
zulässige meinungsäußerung aushalten
sie wehrt sich gegen dieses urteil gut
namen frau künast
guten abend herr kleber während sie in
hamburg für herrn lucke in die bresche
gesprungen gegen überbordende
meinungsfreiheit der studenten die in
niederschrieben ich weiß gar nicht ob
die die geschrieben haben sich wirklich
zu recht auf meinungsfreiheit berufen
hätten glaube ich nicht ich hätte schon
dafür ein
treten mit ihm zu diskutieren und glaube
dass ein professor der früher mal eine
partei gegründet hat mit dem inhalt die
makroökonomische vorlesung beginnen
sollte mit der frage ob das mit der
d-mark sinn macht oder nicht hätte ich
mir so gewünscht aber man hat kein wort
von ihm hören können nun wahr herr lucke
schon auch ein mann der im rechten rand
gefischt hat mit worten wie entartung
von demokratie und der sich mit menschen
aus der rechtsextremen szene um gab hat
er damit ein stück weit meinungsfreiheit
verbirgt nein hat er nicht wir haben ja
in unserem land sehr scharfe und klare
regeln meinungsfreiheit kann man gar
nicht verwirkt es gibt nur ein paar
dinge wo strafbarkeit anfängt wo
parteien aber auch nur in absoluten
ausnahmefällen verboten werden könnten
was aber auch nicht funktioniert weil
wir viel meinungsfreiheit haben nein und
in dem augenblick war auch kein
persönlichkeitsrecht von jemandem
anderen tangiert meines lebens hätte man
an dieser stelle scharf mit ihm
diskutieren müssen und das hätte
aushalten müssen aber kein geschrei kein
sprechverbot kein kein sprechverbot ich
glaube dass wir uns selber keinen
gefallen tun und der demokratie keinen
gefallen tun wenn wir da so rangehen und
ich würde mal sagen angesichts des
rechtsextremismus und dessen was
rechtsextreme in diesem land versuchen
zu verändern einzuschüchtern würde ich
aus meiner sicht immer sagen jetzt
gerade achten wir andersrum auf
meinungsfreiheit
nun hat man aber schon den eindruck dass
manche auf der eher linken szene sich
dinge erlauben die sie rechtsextremen
ganz sicher nicht erlauben würden also
zum beispiel die verhinderung von
öffentlichen auftritten ja denken wir an
den kollegen basierter ein buch
vorstellen wollte und heute im bundestag
glücklicherweise gesagt hat er wird doch
noch mal vorstellen finde ich auch
richtig so mich frustriert dass das
leute jetzt zu dieser methode greifen
gleichwohl ich die breiten rechts und
links für mich vergleichbar halte ja die
einen haben jetzt veranstaltung
verhindert was unklug und falsch war auf
der anderen seite im rechtsextremismus
ist es ja organisiert vom pedal
identitäten bewegung afd die so richtig
versuchen die menschen den menschen
angst zu machen sich in diesem jahr
überhaupt nicht mehr zu engagieren das
sind zwei verschiedene paar schuhe aber
sie finden statt in der aktuellen
allgemeinen erhitzung ich würde mal
sagen runter mit dem hyperventilieren
und wieder meinungsfreiheit und
persönlichkeitsrechte wahren nun um mal
von der deutschen debatte ein bisschen
weg zu kommen weil man da immer gleich
vorurteile hat wenn es um donald trump
geht zum beispiel der hat seine
meinungsfreiheit genutzt indem er immer
wieder rief dass hillary clinton
kriminelle akte begangen habe
locker ab war sein motiv dafür gab es
nie irgendeine faktische grundlage aber
nachdem er das anderthalb jahre lang
wiederholt hat waren millionen
amerikaner der überzeugung dass frau
clinton doch so ein bisschen kriminell
sein müsse wenn man sieht wie diese
mechanismen der verunglimpfung
funktionieren müssen wir dann neue
grenzen ziehen für diese sogenannte
meinungsfreiheit
ich wünsche mir ja auch für mich selber
und viele andere die opfer von rinspeed
sind dass wir mal höchstrichterliche
entscheidung kriegen auch bis hin zum
bundesverfassungsgericht die noch einmal
darauf schauen was haben sie eigentlich
früher in den analogen zeiten
entschieden und passt das heute in der
derzeit in der sachen so systematisch
betrieben werden das war bei trumps oh
das war beim bhc rexit so offensichtlich
teilweise finanziert von den gleichen
leuten ja ich wünsche mir
höchstrichterliche rechtsprechung zur
abgrenzung an dieser stelle aber aber
dass er auch gleichzeitig gefährlich
dann geben sie dem staat wieder mittel
in die hand die meinungsfreiheit nach
gusto einzuschränken das ist ja ein
schwieriges dilemma haben wir aber jetzt
eigentlich schon also die beleidigungs
tatbestände zum beispiel des
strafgesetzbuches machen ja genau die
grenze wo hört meinungsfreiheit auf wo
fängt das persönlichkeitsrecht des
anderen an muss man noch mal scharf
stellt aber was ich noch sagen wollte
das alleine zählt ja am ende gar nicht
nur sondern was wir brauchen ist
natürlich eine gesellschaft die sich
während wir brauchen transparenz bei der
frage wie werden wahlen und abstimmungen
gemacht in den usa erklären sie immer
noch wie viele russische einfluss da war
oder wie trump jetzt noch versucht jetzt
gegen joe biden sozusagen die ukraine in
stellung zu bringen und ähnliches also
daran sieht man es geht nicht nur um
meinungsfreiheit sondern um massives ja
recht brechen in wahlkämpfen bei
abstimmung zum beispiel beim dragset das
ergebnis ist ich glaube dass wir in dem
land nur weiterkommen wenn wir den
offenbar halten wenn wir
meinungsfreiheit hoch halten lieber
diskutieren statt leute verdrängen
aber wir brauchen auch ein rechtsstaat
der mit genug polizei spezialisierten
staatsanwältin gesagt wo die rote linie
ist sonst haben wir ein problem es geht
der kern unseres status unserer
demokratie verloren
eine grüne politikerin fordert eine rote
linien dankeschön frau künast
danke auch das hat heute einen
abendfüllenden termin in berlin deshalb
haben wir dieses gespräch gegen 19 uhr
geführt die nachrichten von heinz wolf
ein entsetzlicher fund beschäftigt die
polizei in großbritannien in einem
industriegebiet östlich von london sind
in einem lkw-anhänger 39 leichen
entdeckt worden ob es sich bei den
opfern um ins land geschleust migranten
handelt es noch nicht klar
die leichen würden derzeit obduziert so
die ermittler der in bulgarien
zugelassene lkw sei per schiff von
belgien nach großbritannien gekommen die
polizei nahm den fahrer einen 25 jahre
alten mann aus nordirland fest er steht
unter mordverdacht
einen tag nach der turbulenten brh exit
abstimmung im parlament in london die
keine entscheidung gebracht hat ist noch
nicht klar wie es weitergeht
die eu berät derzeit über die von
großbritannien formal beantragt die
verschiebung des brh exit datums das
bislang der 31
oktober ist gleichzeitig lehnte johnson
im unterhaus eine verschiedenen heute
erneut ab die fristverlängerung hatte er
auf druck des parlaments bei der eu
beantragt
auch die möglichkeit von neuwahlen war
heute erneut thema in london eine
entscheidung gab es noch nicht
us-präsident trump gerät in der ukraine
affäre weiter unter druck der
amerikanische botschafter in kiew taylor
warf trump in einer vertraulichen
anhörung vor bereits vom kongress
beschlossene us militärhilfe für die
ukraine gezielt zurückgehalten zu haben
um seine politischen rivalen beiden zu
schaden
die rund 400 millionen us-dollar sollten
demnach erst fließen wenn der neue
ukrainische präsident zielinski
öffentlich ermittlungen gegen beiden
ankündigen würde das hatte trump immer
gestritten
die bundesregierung hat weitere teile
ihres klimaschutz paketes auf den weg
gebracht dazu gehört dass ab 2026
grundsätzlich keine ölheizungen mehr
eingebaut werden dürfen
abgesehen von ausnahmefällen auch einen
co2 preis fürs heizen und für den
verkehr hat das kabinett beschlossen
demnach müssen künftig mehr als 4000
unternehmen die mit heizöl erdgas benzin
und diesel handeln
verschmutzungsrechte kaufen und und
länder wollen mit einem förderprogramm
die bildungschancen von schülern in
sozialen brennpunkten verbessern
im rahmen der initiative schule macht
stark werden 125 millionen euro
bereitgestellt damit sollen 200 schulen
gefördert werden mit dem ziel neue
strategien und unterrichtskonzepte zu
entwickeln die leistung der schüler
verbessern zum beispiel in den bereichen
lesen schreiben und mathematik im
vatikan wird derzeit ohne dass man das
in deutschland groß mitbekommt über die
reformfähigkeit und die zukunft der
katholischen kirche beraten und
gestritten
es geht um die themen die auch hier die
debatte beherrschen
der papst hat eine synode seiner
südamerikanischen heimat einberufen
bischöfe und abgesandte eingeladen die
aus dem regenwald des amazonasbeckens
angereist sind um über die
existenziellen sorgen ihre kirche dort
zu berichten verteilt über neun staaten
hauptsächlich brasilien eine fläche die
15 mal so groß ist wie deutschland wo 20
millionen menschen leben davon 200.000
indigene
dort in einer völlig anderen welt erlebt
unser reporter christoph haker rat sind
manche probleme der kirche so anders
nicht als hier und es gibt grund zu
glauben dass aus der not dort ein
stärkerer impuls zu reformen kommen
könnte als aus den satten deutschland
kurz nach sonnenaufgang in manaus die
fähren strömen aus in richtung regenwald
auf einer städtischen kita rallye
missionaren des katholischen hilfswerks
simi das sich speziell um den schutz der
indigenen völker kümmert reden will sie
hier nicht denn er weiß nie wie er
gerade zuhört helfer leben gefährlichen
brasilien immer wieder gibt es drohungen
geworden
vom ufer des amazonas geht es weiter in
richtung regenwald auch wenn von dem
hier nicht mehr viel übrig ist
vernichtet von den rinderzüchter die
ureinwohner aber wollen sich nicht
vertreiben lassen 60 stimme betreute
china hier setzen wir das evangelium in
die praxis um ins echte leben
wir respektieren die andersartigkeit
dieser völker ihre art zu leben ist dem
evangelium viel näher als unseres in der
kapitalistischen welt
wir sind im dorf der mur der stamm wird
von bergbauunternehmen bedroht die das
land wollen erklärt sie über ihre rechte
auf und berät bei alltagsproblemen
es gibt auch eine kleine kirche hier
aber kein pfarrer die amazonas wurde
könnte abhilfe schaffen hofft häuptling
fabio etwa indem sie familienvätern
erlaubt priester zu werden weil es hier
so abgelegen ist kommt nur selten 1
fahrer vorbei wenn wir einfach einen von
uns hier zum fahrer ausbilden könnten
könnten wir öfter eine messe feiern
bei den evangelikalen geht das ja auch
evangelikale gruppierungen breiten sich
massiv aus im katholischen brasilien im
nachbardorf steht schon eine erste
kirche
sie stoßen in die lücken vor die die
katholische kirche mangels priestern
hinterlässt doch viele indigene stört
das aggressive missionieren der
evangelikalen zumal sie oft das wort
jenes mannes predigen den die völker des
regenwaldes als ihre größte bedrohung
ansehen präsident ball zu nahrung die
evangelikalen dringenden unsere
gemeinden ein mit einem denken dass
anders ist als unseres es widerspricht
unserer kultur bei der letzten wahl hat
ein pastor die leute beeinflusst damit
sie diesen korrupten wählen
wir sprechen seinen namen nicht aus den
namen des präsidenten
auch china beobachtet die aktivitäten
der evangelikalen mit sorge viele
gruppen seien direkt mit ball szenario
verbündeten ging es nur um politische
macht nicht um den schutz der schöpfung
doch die schwäche der katholiken sei
hausgemacht sagt sie träge konservativ
frauenfeindlich die synode müsse jetzt
liefern fordert sie warum dürfen die
frauen die sakramente nicht spenden
ich kenne so viele die das hier schon
tun warum erhöhen wenn ich diese zahl
warum dürfen die menschen nicht ihren
beitrag leisten die sich freiwillig
dafür hingeben wollen an der
katholischen kirche kritisiere ich diese
hierarchie und diesen machismus
katholische missionare standen einst an
der seite der konquistadoren die die
neue welt eroberten und zahllosen
indigenen völkern den tod brachten
heute gehört die katholische kirche zu
den wichtigsten verbündeten der völker
des waldes und droht hier nun selbst von
neuen mächten verdrängt zu werden sollte
sie auf der synode in rom keine
antworten für die zukunft finden der
amazonas regenwald mit seiner fähigkeit
co2 zu schlucken und die atmosphäre mit
sauerstoff anzureichern ist ein schatz
der ganzen menschheit unter kontrolle
vor allem einer regierung der
brasilianischen was die dort treibt war
diesen sommer ein riesenthema
wenn wir also heute von dort berichten
geht das nicht ohne den stand der dinge
auch in dieser sache das sieht aus wie
immer im oktober die regenzeit ist da
etwas früher als üblich
die meisten feuer des sommers sind
gelöscht allerdings nicht alle
der regenwald hat mit durch doch es geht
ihm nicht gut
rodungen und brände haben ihnen
zugesetzt wie lange nicht
stand heute gab es seit beginn des
jahres allein im brasilianischen
regenwald mehr als 66.000 brände
fast genauso viele wie im gesamten jahr
davor
eine katastrophe denn der regenwald
bunkert gigatonnen an kohlendioxid er
wird gebraucht auch als wasserspeicher
fliegende flüsse nennt man die million
liter wasser in der feuchten luft die
der wald festhält und weit über den
amazonas verteilt ohnewald droht durch
gehen weitere fünf prozent regenwald
unter würden wir den verteilungs effekt
deutlich ab wir stehen kurz vor dem
kollaps und es geht bis heute immer mehr
regenwald verloren bis september wurden
in diesem jahr etwa in brasilien mehr
als 7800 quadratkilometer regenwald
vernichtet
fast das doppelte im vergleich zum
gleichen zeitraum 2008 zehnter in diesem
jahr wird womöglich erstmals die grenze
von 10.000 quadratkilometern verlorener
bald überschritten
bisher hat der mensch bereits ein
fünftel des gesamten regenwalds im
amazonas vernichtet doch verlorenen
fläche ist nur schwer zu retten einmal
ausgetrocknete boden ist mancher aus
praktisch tot staatliche aufforstung
gibt es nicht und von brasiliens
präsident ball so nahe kommt diese
nachricht man solle den regenwald doch
wirtschaftlich gerne stärker ausbeuten
der wert von ackerland ist auch bei uns
kein problemloses thema kann ich nur wer
ein haus oder eine wohnung kaufen will
muss sich vielerorts mit deutlich
gestiegenen preisen auseinandersetzen
auch für landwirtschaftliche grundstücke
sind die durchschnittlich gezahlten
kaufpreise in den vergangenen jahren
stark nach oben gegangen
das zeigen neue zahlen des statistischen
bundesamtes frank bethmann
wie kommt es zu dieser entwicklung bei
acker und grünland da ist zum einen die
angst vor inflation warum leute boden
kaufen da spielt aber auch zunehmend
eine rolle dass gerade in
ballungszentren immer mehr bauland oder
bauerwartungsland ausgeschrieben wird
also der landwirtschaft gehen im zweifel
flächen verloren auch das treibt den
wert der verbliebenen ackerflächen der
hektar hektar agrarland kostet im
vergangen jahr fast zweieinhalb mal so
viel wie noch 2009 wobei die steigerung
am stärksten in mecklenburg vorpommern
sachsen anhalt sachsen und bayern
ausfielen
während man in bayern möglicherweise
noch am ehesten nachvollziehen kann dass
der grund und boden auch in der
landwirtschaft sehr viel teurer geworden
ist stichwort explodierende
immobilienpreise überrascht die
entwicklung in ostdeutschland dort waren
die äcker lange günstig doch sind sie
seit der finanzkrise ein sicherer hort
für kapital geworden
untersuchungen wie die des thünen
instituts oder der uni götting belegen
dies dort heißt es unter anderem für den
anstieg werden von vielen marktexperten
zunehmend die aktivitäten so genannter
nicht oder außer landwirtschaftlicher
investoren verantwortlich gemacht das
lässt den rückschluss zu dass mit
ackerland inzwischen auch kräftig
spekuliert wird
in bayern dem bundesland mit den
teuersten böden kostet ein hektar im
übrigen inzwischen 65.000 euro
frank bild man vielen dank die
übertragungsrechte der fußball
europameisterschaft ende 2024 in
deutschland hat die telekom erworben
um möglichst alle fußballfans zu
erreichen will das
kommunikationsunternehmen sub lizenzen
verkaufen
zdf-intendant thomas bellut sagte dazu
unser interesse die em 2024 in
irgendeiner form im programm zu haben
besteht weiter wir bleiben für gespräche
mit den rechteinhabern offen
die spiele der deutschen mannschaft
werden aber auf jeden fall frei
empfangbar sein
und wir bleiben noch beim fußball mit
einem ergebnis aus der champions league
da hatte am frühen abend eher beleibt
sich mit 2 1 gegen zenit st petersburg
gewonnen
die sachsen zogen damit in gruppe g am
bisherigen spitzenreiter vorbei und
haben nun sechs punkte auf ihrem konto
und jetzt noch die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
17 16 19 26 31 superzahl 5 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und zdf text auf seite 55 7 es
geht weiter im zdf mit berichterstattung
aus der weiten welt auslandsjournal
elmar theveßen ist das auf einer trump
wahlveranstaltung und sieht die
sicherheit des us präsidenten wird dort
von einer
dies gewährleistet die trainiert und
sich bereit hält zu den waffen zu
greifen
sobald der staat in die freiheit der
bürger eingreift und diese leute meinen
was sie sagen wir auch nur ganz anders
bis morgen wieder sind
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren das hier
ist ein firat druck fällt das besteht
aus den hochs nicola und meiler und den
tiefs flood und wilhelm und so ein
vierer druck fällt ist häufig sehr
stabil
das bedeutet die tiefs verlagern sich
nur langsam und auch die hochs behalten
im wesentlichen ihre lage
das bedeutet es gibt kräftige unwetter
an ort und stelle haben wir jetzt in den
letzten tagen gesehen zum beispiel in
spanien oder auch in südfrankreich und
bald eben auch wieder in italien
was sich bei uns vom wetter kaum ändert
ist der nebel der bindet sich jetzt in
der nacht nämlich wieder neu
die temperaturen sinken auf 10 bis 4
grad und mit viel nebel starten wir dann
morgen auch wieder in den tag nur auf
den berggipfeln da schon von anbeginn
wieder die sonne hochnebel gibt es
allerdings auch im nordosten dieser
nehme sollte sich dann am nachmittag
häufig aufgelöst haben denn der wind
nimmt etwas zu mir kommt aus südlichen
richtungen im nordwesten allerdings
werden die wolken dichter
die höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen an
der küste bei 15 bis 17 grad im
binnenland bei 17 bis 24 grad
in den nächsten tagen bleibt es bei
diesem ruhigen herbstwetter für die
meisten von uns nur an der küste droht
sturm am freitag und samstag und am
sonntag wird es dann deutlich kühler und
damit deutet sich an dass wir einen
temperatursturz erleben werden das sehen
sie hier am trend für dresden sehr schön
dann gibt's nicht mehr temperaturen an
die 20 sondern nur noch werte unter 10
grad
schönen abend noch